As I alluded to during the introduction,
Power BI is much more than a data visualization tool and is capable of
mushing together all those disparate data sources
we need to combine to keep the big boss happy.
Let's look at the Power BI pipeline in more detail.
First, we need to access the data sources that have been
identified that have the core information necessary for the CEO's desire of report.
From there, we use Power Query to connect to
those data sources and load and transform them as necessary.
Queries are the intermediary stage where you perform ETL or extract,
transform and load steps onto
your source data to morph it into
the shape that you need for your data model to perform well.
When you save and apply these queries in Power BI,
they become tables in the data model layer.
Note that each query points to a corresponding data table,
this is meant to reflect that data and transformations that
occur in Power Query align to the data in each of these tables.
Additionally, each of these three tables are connected by
relationships which are symbolized by the black lines connecting the tables.
These relationships tell the Power BI software that the data is
interrelated and allows calculations to flow between the tables,
something that we'll discuss in greater detail
during the relationship segment of this course.
Finally, we can use all of this data to generate a Power BI report,
this reporting layer reflects the output of
your data model in a visual and user friendly manner.
We'll touch on the reporting layer,
but the meat of this course will really focus on layers 1 and 2;
the Power Query layer and the data model layer.
But before we even start on this pipeline,
it's important to understand that we don't want to just
jump straight into getting and modeling data.
First, we need to spend some time figuring out
what information we need to create the queries and build up the data model.
Put it simply, first we plan or we plan to fail.
We need to take the time to learn what the final report should include,
where the data is and if we can access or rely on it.
If we rush into getting and modeling our data without first having this understanding,
we may create a pipeline that doesn't meet the needs of the end users,
and that's when people will notice the bad plumbing.
This planning usually goes in two main parts.
First, the data modeling usually starts with a conversation.
The answer is pretty low tech,
talking it through with folks that know the source data best.
In my experience, this often involves a small group meeting and a big whiteboard.
Then you create your plan for your data model based on what you learned,
which in my experience usually starts with a sketch.
The road map you make for yourself needs to be
informed by key information like the format
of the data sources and the kinds of
relationships you need to create between your data tables.